i'll say well i think they've been able
to predict one of your answers yeah yeah
i know i'm an odd person
[Music]
hi i'm jessica kirsten and i'm here to
answer the internet
oh i need my glasses [ __ ]
would you rather your girlfriend get a
notification every time you watched porn
with a description or a notification of
where you are at all times i'd rather
her get a notification of what i watched
with porn with a description yeah yeah
you don't think she's freaking out by
some of the stuff you're watching yeah
i've heard you talk about your [ __ ] you
want that no i think i think uh anyone i
was with would know when i was watching
like no surprise yeah
but you know you say that but then
sometimes you're still surprised
yeah i know the chickens would be
surprising
[Laughter]
maybe i should rethink that
marry [ __ ] kill brad pitt matthew
mcconaughey or channing
tatum to be honest with you i want to
kill all three of them really yeah not
your type or you just hate it i just
hate everyone those are three not only
the more attractive those three the more
likable i feel like people they are they
well not matthew mcconaughey but i okay
no i want to kill him he annoys the [ __ ]
out of me i'd marry
brad pitt and i would [ __ ] channing
tatum those two were good i don't think
i could kill mcconaughey though oh my
god
what is it you you're like you really
that's the one that's married to the hot
um um hispanic one right yeah yeah i
don't like him it's the whole thing i'm
not into it this question
i don't think we've ever asked it to a
lesbian it totally takes a whole new
form but it works
would you rather [ __ ] the most hideous
girl in the world or an average looking
guy
this is like the perfect question for
jessica oh my god this is so hard
it's gonna sound horrible i mean what
does hideous mean
hideous is like you are like literally a
troll under a bridge you know what i
mean like
almost borderline disfigured you know
average looking guy
would you rather have a dog
this is the hardest one would
would you rather have a dog die every
day
this is so crazy
would you rather have a dog die
i every even say it without laughing
would you
would you rather have a dog die every
time you laugh
or have there be a genocide every time
you fall in love
when you say genocide
i mean i guess at genocide every time i
fall in love
i would just close my heart okay
follow-up question which it is at this
point
which which room people do
[Laughter]
if you could be a master at one of the
four bases of sex would you ha um but
you'd have to be below average at every
other base
which one would you choose what are the
bases for lesbians how do you guys what
would you guys say that is oh god it's
just hand stuff it's kissing hand stuff
mouth stuff full sex right yes
sex is with ripple sex is the most stuff
no
yeah no what's the full sex for you toys
toys
in my mind i guess i'd wanna uh
i'd wanna be um above average at oral i
would everything for a lesbian that
would be the one yeah
if you could be any character from a tv
show who would it be
mork from work and mindy he was just
crazy and odd and wacky
i always loved him yeah would you take a
million dollars to be one of the pic
picket pocket
oh picket people for the westboro
baptist church during a fallen soldier's
funeral
what
that's amazing
i know this is like a tongue twister and
then and then the picture says god hates
you like a sign with god hates you would
i take a million dollars for that
absolutely not i'd rather
anything
i get why you guys would do it but i
couldn't do it i can't wait you just
come back i get why you vermin me well
because you're not i i know so many gay
people like it's just horrible what they
do
and that just wouldn't affect me no
because you're a breeder
i can't get why you bigots
[Music]
would you rather have 50 grand straight
to your bank account or a half a million
in pennies and you can't convert it a
half a million in pennies
i'm jewish i'll find a way
[Laughter]
would you rather live your life as is or
be a billionaire but you have to blow a
dude every day oh my god this is so hard
live my life as is
i'll say well i think they've been able
to predict one of your answers yeah yeah
i know i'm an odd person billion i don't
care i can make it on my own
and i will
not a billion but i'll do well
i know i'm
not disappointing you but i'm being
honest
once a year is another story
if can i be in a blackout i'd have to
relapse oh jesus
this is getting worse and worse
all right one last question for you
would you rather have a an unlimited
amount of the whistle pig rye whiskey
aged six years or the 10-year trick
question your buffoons because they're
both the best whiskey on the planet
earth for this six year
classy and spicy classic mix you can get
them right now at your local retailer or
go to whistlebigwhiskey.com
it's the best in the business
if you're watching on youtube click here
to subscribe so you get all the new
episodes as they come out and john what
should they click if they want
notifications
make sure you click thumbs up for the
like hit that bell icon